yes the Crimson ballot a very rare and
unique item that has found its way into
your hands now when the time is right
the spell that will awaken and open a
gate between worlds a passage that will
guide you all the way to the subscribe
button for the new world review and
pressing it will ensure more Berzerk
related content uploaded straight until
YouTube feeds
hello and welcome to the new I'll review
your source for everything anime and
manga and today I'm going to take this
opportunity to discuss a series that I
see a request for in my comment section
at least once per video being berserk
very specifically why you yes you need
to read beserk and if you've already
read berserk then this is your biannual
reminder to read it again because why
not those have you got to do so despite
the fact that I have not covered it on
this channel before primarily because I
wasn't sure how much interest there
would be on berserk related content this
series is one that has really stuck with
me throughout the years and only seems
to provide more and more value with each
subsequent rereading of it and if you're
an on beserk fan watching this and
wondering why I'm focusing so much on
reading the manga rather than say
watching the anime or even movies and
stay tuned because you know we will
certainly cover that and I'd also like
to add a caveat to this discussion which
is unlike most things I cover on this
channel I do not think that berserk
holds an innate universal appeal you
need to be very willing to open yourself
up to it
and in many cases even challenge
yourself with the material presented
however the reward for doing so is
immeasurable so let's begin this
exploration with quite probably the most
common factor of praise brought up in
regards to berserk which is its art now
honestly I feel quite stereotypical and
just a little bit boring stating that
mate you need to read berserk because
art and that's because I'm sure many of
you have had this exact experience where
you're speaking to a berserk fan and the
topic of art comes up and instead of
them actually telling you what is so
good about it
they just visibly jizz in their pants
and promptly excuse themselves to clean
it up however when this manga features
quite possibly objectively the finest
art in the entire medium it's pretty
hard to avoid acknowledging this point
immediately
Cantara Mira has an absurd mastery of
conveying atmosphere in a
two-dimensional format with the most
effective use of lighting that I think
I've ever seen in comics in general
which is so ridiculously important in
providing depth into this world he has
crafted because through his god-like
control of lighting on a page he has the
power to plunge us into the deepest
depths of hell but at the same time
Miura can also portray some of the most
profound angelic majesty as well as
everything in between
berserk is an extremely turn
we'll experience at all times and it
really allows the reader to become
completely immersed in its art and of
course it's not all about light either
but also any number of deeply tangible
features like texture for example when
Mira wants to convey something is
particularly rough like say almost any
time guts is on a page then he will do
so with intricately flowing in jagged
lines to provide this very coarse
appearance however on the flip side he
can also craft existences that feel
genuinely supernaturally smooth even if
you're just taking it in with your eyes
and once again Mira can also produce
everything in between which means that
every character every landscape every
object in berserk is given its own
individually crafted texture to have it
stand out in this world and in this art
section I also want to potentially
dispel a concern that many people are
going to have going into pisac which is
in terms of its content and specifically
in terms of it being all too dark
so yes berserks art well as I said
plunge you into the deepest depths of
Hell but that is not nearest soul focus
and he juxtaposes that content quite
brilliantly with opposing forces of pure
innate beauty and there's also moments
very simplistic and flat-out for the
sake of comedy so there is so so much
more for the eyes to feast on in berserk
than just hellish demons and every
subsequent page you take in will reward
you with a new experience and the
greatest thing about berserk is that
Mira is a world-class artist from the
get-go his style does evolve and refine
over time as with all manga car but the
difference in quality between chapter 1
of berserk and chapter 359 is like
comparing a diamond to an even bigger
diamond they're both pretty damn
breathtaking it's not like when you go
back two decades and look at say the
very first chapter of one piece and go
oh well we've certainly come a long way
since those days and I think the auras
artistic consistency really assists in
creating a cohesive experience over the
lifespan of berserk alright that's
enough about Arthur because that might
be enough to appeal to aesthetic demons
like myself but the next reason you
should absolutely read berserk is for
its glorious and well explored
characters another nice vague statement
that you probably hear in regards to a
lot of series but let me make it very
clear just how far and above berserks
it's from characters in the large
majority of other manga series just as
with its tangible art style characters
in Berserker granted exceptional depths
and are scattered all the way across
every ideological spectrum imaginable
the large majority of residents in
berserk carry with them a sense of great
evil great good and even a hint of wow
that's pretty effed up with one of the
greatest examples of this being finest a
curve and image
and don't like at me with the
pronunciation of this it definitely
isn't fine nice and yes I do know that
my Italian sucks but that's just how
things going to be in any case fine
assay is about as complex of a character
as one could possibly be managing to
embody one of the more incredible
sources of kindness in the series but at
the same time also being a person
capable of masturbating to the thought
of burning heretics at the stake so how
the hell does that work out well
reiden find out she's a very tricky
character though and no singular
experience of fantasy in any chapter
could possibly give you the full sense
of who she is which is very very common
in berserk characters need a lot of time
to unfold and you often won't get a full
sense of them until the completion of a
rather lengthy arc but that is
incredibly compelling because each and
every one of them presents a mystery
where you're never quite sure what twist
is going to come next
and this isn't say that berserk is a
completely morally grey series either
where there is like no true good or evil
there are most certainly both of those
but they are explored on a very hyper
scale such as with the primary
antagonist of the series godhand
despite being the epitome of evil these
guys are never flat or boring and their
presence within this world is both
genuinely intriguing and profoundly
terrifying particularly in the case of a
certain femme tone + berserk has a lot
of small victories with its characters
such as being one of the super super
rare series in the world to have created
a main stage child character who is not
the most annoying existence on the
planet actually turns out to be
something of a master class of how to
effectively incorporate a child into
really any story and of course I haven't
even touched on the heart and soul of
berserk being guts and Casca but really
the less said about them out of context
the better let's just say they are
perfectly capable of helming a story
like berserk which speaking of the
number three reason why you need ribs
arc is simply because of the story and
it's ever evolving nature something
which you probably won't get from an
outside experience of berserk is that it
certainly does not stay one note it
starts out as something of a demon
hunter revenge seeking peace but over
the course of a handful of arcs berserk
transforms into something truly
unrecognizable from what it was when it
began which is certainly not a bad thing
in fact I personally really enjoy the
berserkers engaged in a very fluid
evolution of story and like most series
yeah there's a primary goal here and
there but for the most part the reader
just like the characters end up being
swept away in this grand fantasy and a
lot of time the story focuses on
characters adjusting to the radically
changing world around them so it has
this low
natural progression about it now opposed
characters in art I would say that the
story is far from perfect and I think
that it does have its own golden age
which ironically is not the Golden Age
arc conviction arc is peak berserk IMO
but the greater story itself always
manages to remain supremely intriguing
and its various explosive climaxes will
leave you appropriately stunned and
amazed which is going to lead into
delightful reason and before to pick up
zerk which is an incredible depth of
world heart story and characters are
absolutely nothing in my eyes without an
exceptional stage and set designed to
play upon and berserk certainly answers
that call by providing a rich landscape
with no lack of political historical and
mystical intrigue in fact at times it
really does give you the feeling that
you have stepped into a part of history
because every location in this world
appears to have a lengthy past that
hasn't formed every decision that is
being made to this day and it really
helps them all feel so much more natural
and continues that idea of characters
being swept up in something far greater
than themselves
but berserk goes a lot further than that
and flushes out alternate planes of
existence and how they interact with the
standard mortal realm as we know it with
pretty unbelievable detail as well
although it does strike a find balance
and doesn't reveal too much leaving some
great layers of mystery for us to ponder
and you know a very fascinating example
of this would be what is known as the
lost chapter of desert which Meera
emitted from deserts volume release and
thus the Canon because it gave just a
little bit too much away about the
overall depth of the world which shows
that Meera has a keen sense of
maintaining mystery and allowing
continued versatility with writing but
in general berserk really does present
its readers with a Tolkien like
landscape where the more you delve into
it the more you realize how truly rich
it is now as for reason number five we
have the exploration of ideas ever so
many ideas most of which we can very
plainly personally identify with such as
betrayal corruption loneliness anger
darkness despair all of that human
goodness that the reader can feel on a
very visceral level but the ideas of
berserk also break out into the more
philosophically complex and in
particular and quite like how the series
decides to tackle the overall issue of
religion I think it's an incredibly
honest take on what causes religion to
commence thrive and even fall as well as
challenging the concept of faith in
general and if you're religious then
maybe that doesn't sound so great to you
but faith itself is an idea that is up
for grabs in berserk when should you
have faith what should you have faith in
and so in the end I don't think berserk
condemns religion as much as it makes
commentary on a religious institution
if that makes sense that is one mere
very mere aspect of berserk because it
does the same with political power
warfare and a lot of broad societal
issues and it even goes a step further
to tackle one of the greatest questions
of humanity which is the very concept of
good and evil and what can be considered
what and then even if it is classified
could it even be that simple and Mura
does this by way of various means one of
my favorites is purely aesthetic so a
lot of times in berserk you will run
into a case where something angelically
beautiful ends up being one of the
greatest sources of darkness meanwhile
something ugly and broken represents the
greatest reservoir of hope in the world
there's an awful lot to play with in
berserk including the idea that
everything is just subject to the law of
causality and essentially everything we
do is by and large meaningless with a
predetermined outcome or is it no no
it's kind of up to you and the
characters to decide that for yourselves
now as for reason number six as to why
one needs to read bizarre specifically
it's because there honestly just is not
a competent anime incarnation of it so
even if you're not a beserk fan most
anime enthusiasts I've probably heard
about the debacle that is the 2016
incarnation series famous for its
uncanny valley character models and
animation but also for chopping out some
really key stuff from the manga and all
around just presenting a very
watered-down product that will never
come anywhere near close to giving you
the highest highs or the lowest lows
from the manga experience and the cons
say it gets much better in other
incarnations either the 1997 anime is
aged to say the least
I'd say withered beyond belief and it
also cuts very integral characters and
story elements I think the best chance
one would probably have is with the
three films that adapt the Golden Age
events and even then there are some
choices made in these that just don't
make it an ideal berserk experience in
my opinion so there is currently no
substitute for the manga nothing else
can provide you that raw shot of berserk
straight into your veins and if you're
not after that sort of experience then I
understand berserk is not for everyone
but if you are going to do it then I
cannot comprehend why you would want to
experience it as anything less than it
should be
let me aura drag you to hell take a tour
of heaven and struggle on earth which
paves the way for my final reason to
read berserk which is simply to
challenge yourself berserk is not a kind
series that will hold your hand and
guide you through a story it thrusts you
into an established world and tells you
to survive on your own it will confront
you with unimaginable horrors grotesque
violence much of which includes a high
degree of sexual violence as well by the
way but it will also present you with
all that is good in the world in
love friendship mate chip on a belief
and everything else on that side of the
spectrum but what Berzerk does not do is
mask either of these it will give you
the absolute darkness as well as the
piercing light and as a reader it is
your job to explore all of that and make
up your own mind about some of the
tougher questions of the world because
as much as this is a dark fantasy piece
it very much reflects the common
existence of real world human society
and when our world can be so easily
compared with sickening demonic
presences then that can be uncomfortable
but at the very least it does allow the
reader to think for themselves and come
to their own conclusions and it is for
these seven and really many many more
reasons that if you are so inclined I
would strongly recommend that you read
berserk but what do you guys think
please to leave your thoughts in the
comments below will even join my discord
server and if you're keen for some more
bizarre style content then please do let
me know by subscribing to the channel as
a result of this video because I would
love to make more if there is a keen
interest for it but for now this has
been the new world review and I'll see
you next time